je vais jouer pour mettre ce panier et
pour te donner moi-même 5000 euros
est-ce que tu te rends compte dans quel
monde on vit
c'est vrai
vous êtes loin quand même c'est loin
c'est trop loin c'est trop loin
appeler un dernier ami et ça sera ta
dernière chance
je connais un gars qui a un pote à moi
je sais pas s'il est dans le quartier
mais je peux peut-être l'appeler
est-ce que Rudy Gobert est dans le
quartier
[Applaudissements]
c'est un immense champion Rudy c'est
joli c'est peut-être le plus grand
sportif français et peut-être de tous
les temps parce que Rudy il est
tellement humble qu'on peut parler mais
c'est vraiment jolie c'est une sommité
c'est un mec qui voilà c'est une star
aux États-Unis c'est une star partout je
suis tellement heureux
[Rires]
alors là 1m90
finaliste bien sûr de l'euro de basket
l'équipe de France qui a été formidable
on embrasse tous les joueurs de l'équipe
de France et Rudy je voudrais le dire
encore voilà je sais que je sais pas
s'il y en a qui suivent le basket mais
je vous dis c'est vraiment peut-être la
plus grande star du sport français c'est
énorme voilà ce qui fait aux États-Unis
c'est une immense star et Rudy c'est
vrai que je suis pas ta gueule tu es
tranquille tu fais ta vie non mais c'est
vrai je te jure c'est incroyable et tu
sais que je t'ai vu tout à l'heure parce
qu'on s'est vu tout à l'heure on s'est
croisé dans la rue et ouais et j'ai vu
je lui ai dit que j'avais beaucoup cette
petite de cette nouvelle couleur j'ai
regardé pendant les matchs j'ai kiffé
j'ai dit mais quand je le verrai je lui
dirai Rudy je sais que tu vas jouer pour
Janick
Janique tu le regardes on dirait que tu
le menaces
ne menace pas les gens
tu n'es pas venu ici pour me lasser des
gens
si tu mets le panier gagnera 5000 €. si
tu mets pas le panier
par contre si tu le mets pas faut que je
mette de haut d'ici
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas le même hein
déjà c'est pas facile et j'apprécie
attention
[Applaudissements]
si tu ne le mets pas Rudy
malheureusement Janique verra les 5000 €
s'envoler et l'ensemble de sa vie
[Applaudissements]
tu as un ami
donc je vais faire une dérogation
je vais te laisser 3 essais
supplémentaires
[Applaudissements]
sixième médaille international pour Rudy
j'en ai pas fini avec toi
à côté de moi juste avant
je voudrais revoir des images de contre
la Tunisie l'équipe de France ça
cartonné d'ailleurs la finale sur M6
dimanche soir regarde
le sacroche mais comme trop souvent les
balles perdus s'accumulent en face les
Turcs qu'on retrouvait leur basket et
affiche maintenant une adresse insolente
malgré tout la France est toujours dans
le match dans les ultimes secondaires il
suffit d'un panier pour forcer la
prolongation le flotteur
[Musique]
il y aura encore une balle de match pour
les Français au moins pour aller
chercher la prolongation Thomas Heurtel
Thomas Heurtel avec la plancha c'est
rentré bon on revient de loin on nous
beurre fois
[Applaudissements]
je vais la voir ça
le contre de Rudy c'est incroyable
tu as un nouveau club maintenant tu es
bien là-bas où ça ton nouveau club
écoute j'y vais dans quelques jours ça
t'est bien que tu as pris tes marques et
tout super content parce que ça a été
quand même le transfert on dit transfert
on dit pas transfert là-bas on dit quoi
on dit draft c'est ça
a été tout le monde en a parlé donc la
théorie
l'objectif c'est d'être vraiment
j'ai fait 9 ans là-bas
faut passer à une étape une étape
supérieure le stade différent je pense
ça va être énorme valérité ton fils doit
être content d'avoir
Janick j'ai une question à te poser tu
as gagné 5000 euros
mais ici tu sais rien ne se passe comme
ça
c'est où tu gagnes ces 5000 euros
tu rentreras chez toi avec ton papa avec
quelqu'un vous connaissez non non
quelqu'un qui tu vas faire qui tu vas
faire connaissance
ou bien
tu décides de renoncer aux 5000 euros et
là un superbe coffret évasion non en duo
pour tout le public séjour repas
au public donc non mais les mecs
la production si vous avez un problème
vous allez voir Lionel Stan
directeur général l'âge de zoo s'il vous
plaît on vous a pas demandé votre avis
vous le demandera tout à l'heure vous
aurez des petits pancarte vous le
donnerai est-ce qu'il peut faire le
téléphone à son papa pour savoir son
avis quand vous serez productif dans
l'émission
pour l'instant je veux qu'il prenne ses
décisions seul Janique c'est quelqu'un
qui était en grande difficulté scolaire
en troisième
[Rires]
et là Janique
il doit prendre sa décision seule alone
et bien c'est avec regret que je dois
renoncer à faire plaisir au public je
vais garder les
[Applaudissements]
si tu veux tu peux bien sûr le public il
a pas son cadeau il a pris quand même
bien sûr faire un tour et faire un doigt
à tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est voilà
ton père même ton père vas-y
Janick a gagné les 5000 euros
et le public le public n'a
malheureusement rien gagné merci à eux
d'être venu
ça va oui mais les chéris on peut pas
c'est pas la fête on peut pas tout
donner on peut pas tout avec tout gagner
voilà Rudy était formidable avec
le mardi c'est la fête
tu vois tu l'as malade
il s'en fout totalement voilà faire en
trois pattes je peux t'offrir un coffret
évasion
[Rires]
pardon deux jours
il faut que tu m'invites un jour
je reste avec lui
je suis content je voudrais dire encore
une fois et
fantastique il a été élu dans le 5 les 5
meilleurs joueurs de l'euro vous avez
fait rêver contre la Turquie l'Italie la
Pologne alors il y a une petite
déception que vous avez parce que vous
avez perdu en finale mais toute la
France a révélé de cette équipe
fantastique de basket bravo
il est juste venu nous voir voilà Rudy
il nous a fait l'honneur de venir nous
voir je voudrais remercier qu'on a pas
eu très fort rudy Gobert cet après-midi
d'amour on t'aime Aurélie vous êtes
libéré parce que on m'a dit que je vais
te libérer merci pour Willy
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon petit cadeau je vais t'offrir
un ballon dédicacé
[Rires]
malheureusement t'inquiète pas merci
[Applaudissements]